compact light and stylish here are three
reasons you should get the MSI summon
e13 flip Evo a3m with 14 hours of
battery life you're hardly ever going to
reach for that charging cable and if
you're ever in a pinch you can charge it
up to 60% battery after 53 minutes of
fast charging if you really need some
juice with a 70w hour battery you can
rest easy the summit e113 flip Evo a13 M
comes with an MSI pen that has two types
of pen tips fiber and P and its
sensitivity is only at 40% so you can
avoid unwanted scribblings it feels
great that draw it and has great tilt
angles it has a 10 mm hover view so you
can preview options without touching the
screen and you can use it for
presentations as a remote for slides
talk about bang for your buck you get a
sketch take notes and present everything
all in one package accidents happen all
the time and sometimes it might not be
you that causes them in order to curb
any unfortunate accidents the laptop is
also military grain and can withstand
shocks high temperatures and more if
anything were to happen to it it would
still be in amazing shape would you get
it tell us